let's say that you have some vials here
and you know that in the solution you
have fragments of dna in each of these
and what you're curious about well what
about the dna fragments in our in this
first violin vial number one how long
are those fragments how many base pairs
how long are they well you might say
well why don't i just take them out and
count them
except for the fact that they are
incredibly small and incredibly hard to
handle even a fairly large fragment of
dna let's say we're talking about
something that's on the order of five
thousand
five thousand base pairs well that's
going to be approximately one to two
micrometers long if you were to
completely stretch it out and and we
can't even start to think about how thin
the the actual diameter is if we just
but lengthwise the long way it's only
going to be one to two micrometers which
is super duper small this is one to two
thousandths of a millimeter so that's
not going to help us to somehow try to
manipulate it
physically with our with our hands or
with the you know kind of rough tools so
how do we do that and we could have
other vials there how do we see how long
the dna strands that are sitting in
those vials actually are and the
technique we're going to use gel
electrophoresis it actually could be
used for dna strands it could be used
for rna can also be used for proteins
any of these macromolecules to see how
long are those fragments and so let me
write this down
gel
electrophoresis
electrophoresis
and it's called gel electrophoresis
because it involves a gel it involves it
involves electric charge and phoresis is
just referring to the fact that we are
going to cause the dna fragments to
migrate through a gel because of the
charge so phoresis is referring to the
migration or the movement of the actual
dna
so how do we do this well here is our
setup right over here we have our
our gel
that's inside of a that's that's
embedded in a in a buffer solution so
this gel the most typical one is agarose
gel that's a polysaccharide that we get
from seaweed and it's literally a gel
it's a gelatinous material
and what we're going to do is is we're
going to put we're going to take samples
so we might take a little sample from
this one right over here and we'll put
it in
this well
right over here and you can view these
wells as little divots in the gel you
could take a little sample from here and
put it into
this well
and then you could put a sample from
here and you could put it in that well
and it's going to be made inside this
buffer so you can see the buffer i drew
this fluid and that's really just water
with some salt in it and the buffer is
going to keep the ph from going
too far out of bounds as we place a
charge across this entire thing because
if the ph gets too far in the basic or
acidic side it might actually affect the
dna or affect the charge on the dna and
what we're going to do is we're going to
put a charge across this whole this
whole setup where the side where the
wells are where we're going to place the
dna that's going to be where we're going
to put the negative the negative
electrode so that's our negative
electrode there and the other end is
going to be our
is going to be our positive electrode
and we're going to let use the fact that
dna is has a negative charge at the
typical phs right like the ph's that we
are going to be dealing with and we
could go back
into previous videos and we can see it
right over here you see these negative
charges on our phosphate backbone
and so what is going to happen
what is going to happen once we once we
connect both of these to a power source
and then this side is negative and this
side is positive well the dna is going
to want to migrate
now let's think about what will happen
will
shorter things migrate further or will
longer things migrate further
well you might say well longer things
are going to have more negative charge
so maybe they go farther away but then
you also have to remember that they're
also moving more mass so their charge
per mass is going to be the same
regardless of length and so what
determines how far something gets how
much it how much it migrates over a
certain amount of time is how small it
is remember we have this
agarose gel and people are still
studying the exact mechanism of how this
dna or these macromolecules actually
migrate through the polysaccharide but
if you imagine this polysaccharide is
kind of this this mesh this net the
sieve well smaller things are going to
be able to go through the gaps easier
than the larger things and so if you let
some time pass
if you let some time pass some of the
dna let's say this dna gets
around there let's say and i'm just
color you actually wouldn't see these
colors let's say this dna gets around
that far so it doesn't get as far let's
say that this dna doesn't migrate let's
say it has some that migrates that far
and let's say it has some
that migrates that far
and so if you just saw this you wait
some amount of time and you were to come
back and you were to see this this
migration that you were to see
this migration occur and the longer you
wait the longer the mic the further
these things are going to get in fact if
you wait too long they're going to fall
off all all the way over the other edge
is if you just saw this you'd say okay
well this this strand right over here
these must be smaller dna molecules they
must be shorter these must be a little
bit longer and these must be even longer
than that and this grouping right over
here is going to be the longest of all
so this was a mixture of some longer
strands and still longer ones but not
quite as long and for example maybe
maybe there are some really short
strands
maybe there are some really short
strands in that what i'm drawing as
what i'm drawing as that orange group
right over here
so what i just did right over here this
will tell this would this could tell you
the relative
length of these strands but how would
you actually measure them
well that's where you can go find
standardized solutions
which we call a dna ladder
so let's say you go get the dna ladder
i'm going to draw it in pink so you
literally could buy this you could even
buy it online and the standard solution
let's say it separates like this so it
separates like that goes there let's say
some of it goes like there and some of
it goes
like there
well you would be able to know from the
labeling or whichever one you choose to
buy that this grouping here these this
is all of the dna that is 5000 base
pairs let's say let's say this right
over here is 1500
base pairs and let's say this over here
is let's say this over here is 500
base pairs long and so now you can use
this dna ladder these standardized ones
to gauge how long the d how many base
pairs these are so you say okay this is
this blue one here this is a bunch of
dna that's a little bit longer than 500
base pairs but it's shorter than 1500
base pairs you can see this this green
one here well it's a little bit longer
than 1500 base pairs it didn't migrate
quite as far as this big bundle of 1500
base pairs did and so then you can get a
better approximation and you can choose
your ladder based on what you think you
are going to find there what you are
actually going what you're actually
going to look for now the other thing to
appreciate is when you see
when you see the the dna having migrated
this far you might say okay is this one
dna strand is that one dna strand that
i'm looking at
and just going back to the measurements
no that is many many many many dnas that
you're looking at and this is they're
not all stretched out like that remember
even something that is 5 000 base pairs
long is going is only going to be one to
two micrometers if you stretch it out so
wouldn't you be able to see it it's a
thousandth of a millimeter you wouldn't
even be able to see it so this is many
many many mount molecules of dna
is migrating that far and they would
have to be that small to be able to
migrate through that polysaccharide gel
now the last thing you're probably
saying is okay wait but how am i even
seeing it over here how do i actually
see this dna especially if there are
these super super small molecules and
the answer is you put some type of
marker on the dna that will make them
visible some type of dye or something
that might become fluorescent and one of
the typical things that people often use
is ethidium bromide and the thidium
bromide is called an intercalating agent
and it's a molecule you can see the
ethydium right over here these are two
dna
two
backbones of dna you can see the base
pairs bonding here and then this right
over here
that
is ethidium that has fit itself that's
what that's why we call it intercalating
it has fit itself in between the rungs
of the ladder and when it does so inside
of dna it actually becomes fluorescent
when you apply uv light to it so if you
put this ethidium bromide
into all of your dna
right over here and then as it migrates
and then if you were to turn on a uv
light it would become fluorescent and
you would actually see these things and
so if you wanted to see what it actually
would look like in real life well this
is what it would look like when you were
to if you were to look at it straight on
where this would have been a well
let me make it a little bit easier to
read
so right over here would have been the
well where you would put the dna ladder
and it would come up with standardized
measurements maybe that's our 5000
base pairs
this right over here is our 1500
base pairs and this right over here is
our 500
base pairs and then let's say you had
some solution of some other dna and you
wait a little while and you see look it
migrated not quite as far as a 500 base
pair so it must be a little bit this
must be a bundle of things a little bit
longer than 500 base pairs but for sure
a lot shorter than 1500 base pairs and
once again it doesn't have to have just
one fragment length you could have had
another group that was maybe right at
1500 base pairs and you've probably seen
this whenever you see people talking
about genetic analysis and things like
this you're often seeing people looking
at one of these readouts from gel
electrophoresis so now you know what's
actually going on here this isn't a
strand of dna this is a big there's a
bunch of dna that has been tagged with
some type of a dye or or the ethidium
bromide idiom bromide or something like
that and it's a bunch of those molecules
and they've migrated based on the charge
they're trying to get away from that
negative charge to the positive charge
and the smaller molecules this is a
bunch of small molecules right over here
are able to get further because they're
able to get through the mesh of the
agarose gel